one of the things that I really think
through is this trade-off between you
know convenience and privacy or security
and I think you're highlighting it here
of like we all want the cell phone so we
walk around with it because we can call
people we could get on the internet on
Instagram old stuff but it also provides
now a tracking device a listening device
etc I don't think we've really seen kind
of at least across the American
population in certain examples we've
seen it but not yet where those have
been used to steal freedom of movement
or kind of bigger kind of freedoms we're
seeing that now though where you see
Google creating these tracking tools
where they say hey we're gonna use the
cell phone data and we're gonna be able
to tell you are you social distancing or
not and we're gonna give that data to
the government and yeah we may anonymize
it we may you know kind of aggregate it
supposedly but when you start to enter
into that world where now that data
isn't just let's start let's stop
terrorist attacks it's now let's prevent
you and me from going and meeting up
with each other really slippery slope it
seems yeah that's too far right we're
having private organizations that are
enabling portions of our everyday lives
and our like for me my phone is is how I
make my living like whether it's you
know through photographs or through
communication you know or through social
media and that they have they have
weaponized the phone
we're like the distance of that I am
from other people how many people are
with me what we're talking about like
what is next so first they're saying how
many people are congregating at what
distance and then then are they saying
okay well not only are we gonna are we
gonna be intrusive about that let's also
they're here's some things that they're
not allowed to do when they're together
so they're not allowed to what worship
they're not allowed to negatively
disparage ly talk about President Trump
or President Biden or whoever it's gonna
be like who knows like what once that we
keep saying slippery slope so that
metaphor is like
after a couple of once momentum
negatively starts happening and there's
no way that you can stop the negative
energy that continues down this slippery
Hill so if this is a hill and you're on
top of it and then you make a bad
decision and you give up a little bit of
your freedom you're on this side of hill
and then you make another one
now you move two times down but this
look is super slippery and now I'm
sliding down and there's nothing that I
can do about it as I slowly go all the
way down this hairy troll ish arm and
fall off to my mouth and it and I think
that seems like in this alarmist thing
we're like no slippery slope
that's what alarmist that's what like
Preppers use as excuses to have a bunch
of chickens and have a farm and have
their own well and have their own solar
and have a bunch of medical talk about
myself right now
and I'm super happy well there is one
want to have you come on and talk about
this right is there's this weird balance
between you're not the guy who's yelling
and screaming you know [ __ ] the
government actually you are enlisted
United States military you are a trained
Green Beret Ranger qualified you've
spent you know what almost two decades
of your life dedicated to protecting the
American Way of life American freedom
etc and I think actually what people
confuse is like those people who are in
the military police fire right all of
those that are sworn to protect the
American Way of life they actually feel
the strongest about this right that
they're the ones who are saying wait a
minute timeout this is not what is
supposed to be happening
at home yeah but people look at my
resume and they're like oh that's the
guy that's gonna come kicking my doors
to take a gun like brothers you're
insane
right like I have watched my friends
burn alive inside of vehicles that got
blown up by IEDs fighting to protect
these freedoms and you think I'm going
to go and enforce the taking of those
away from you you're saying right like
you're talking about the most passionate
freedom loving group of people in the
planet it is your law enforcement it's
your firefighters and your military
right because they have seen firsthand
the suffering and the sacrifice that
goes in to the protection and the
preservation of those things and for the
military especially we go to places
where these freedoms don't exist so
every time I start having a conversation
about you know capitalism versus
socialism just economically or like the
practice of communism as a form of
government versus a republic as if or we
have these have you ever lived or spent
time in a place that practices the form
of government that you are supporting if
you haven't why don't you come with me
for a few weeks because I have and the
whole entire time that we're there the
only reason I was able to survive was
because the military was flying in my
food in water because there wasn't any
there if you wouldn't have gotten the
water out of the the well you'd have
dysentery because it has been poisoned
by all the gross people that are around
there because there's no food or water
to be at and everybody's fighting they
freaking well it is clearly I and
everybody that every single one of my
brothers and sisters that have has worn
that flag on their soldier on their on
their shoulder you have confidence that
we are the ones that loves freedom and
that have died and I've seen her and
actually her friends died protecting it
and would happily die to protect it